咱接着再说一会儿吧，好吧。
为啥呢？
因为。
这10个类型我说完之后啊。
这个这个同学跟我反映说听不懂啊。
信其实不是听不懂，是信息量太大，脑子一下有点糊了。
这节课确实很长啊。
所以我喝了一瓶红牛，补充一下能量。
呃，接着给大家再再再再往下说一说。
我再重申一遍啊。
这10个类型。
我们可以理解为10个讲故事的方式，思路是讲故事的类型。
从影片的角度来讲，当然有单一类型的金相毛片，单一类型的麻烦家伙片。但是比如说像爱情。
爱情啊经常可以装进每一个里面。
我们说麻烦家伙行。
周星驰的最爱。
他很多片子都是这样的，但是他往往装一个爱情在里面。
周星驰的每一个片子都装爱情，他从来不把爱情撇掉。
明白这个意思吧？但是他也从来不单独拍爱情片。
明白这个意思吧？
他有时候一个片子里面甚至装好几个爱情。
他跟一个女的爱情，另外她再跟达叔再来一个。
就他跟达叔也是互补。
他跟达叔也是互补。我们说爱情片所有的情感类的片子全都属于爱情片。
就两个人情感上彼此需要都属于爱情啊，都属于情感类。
麻烦家伙类的片子。
青爷。
往往装一个钟立奇，再装一个大叔，你懂我意思吗？可瘫了，然后再拍一个麻烦家伙累的故事。
然后他也会你说变签仪式里面装不了爱情吗？
娱热成功里面装不了爱情吗？被制度化里面装不了爱情吗？啊，都能装。
都可以装，对吧？都可以装。
怎么去理解这个。
我再举我再说一遍。
怎么帮助大家理解这10个类型啊？
金羊毛类我们去想一下来。
你们说这种类型的片子最多。
徐峥的。
还是这种基本上全是这种嘛，新花路放太久。
对吧不管是他拍的，还是他演的吧，他就喜欢搞这一套。
然后我们说任务类的十一罗汉这种。
强点啥，偷点啥，要去办一个什么事儿，就周密的计划，商量要去办一个事儿的，也都属于这类型。
还有啥呢？比如说我说的绿野仙踪西游记这种取经类的对吧？还有公路片、阳光小美女公路片的巅峰之作呀，阳阳光小美女大家一定要去看一下，好吧，这每个教材里面都会举例的牛逼的片子。
理解一下爱情片，我们说单独成片的已经很少了。
已经很少了。
肿瘤菌可能算。
那个那个。
我不太记得剧情了啊，应该是爱情片。
然后那个办个喜剧算。
泰坦尼克号的那个杰克和rose。
呃，那一段大部分吧大部分吧可以归在这里面。
超级英雄类的这就多了。
超级英雄片不是单指所有的那种漫威片啊或者DC片那种。
那种类型的超级英雄，有的时候一个很很棒的警察，或者是一个。
呃，那个那个武士，一个战士，他也算这种就强男一，明白这个意思吧？我经常说的强男一的片子，它也是这个类型的片子，能力使呃命门对手使命。
他也是这种类型的片子。
然后鬼屋片其实就是我们理解的灾难片。
明白这个意思吗？就是关起门来出事了，这种类型其实是特别多的。
国外特别多的，国内很少，国内为啥很少啊？因为这个力量。
呃搞不搞不太好，对吧？其实大白鲨类的算。
对吧。
咱们中国弄过巨齿鲨。
鲨鱼嘛，杰斯赛森和李冰冰那个。
就说这种超自然力量咱们审查是能过的。
大鲨鱼这种是可以过的，但是他又吃特效。所以说这类片子咱们确实少。
然后侦探片子我们说不一定是侦探。
理解吧？不一定是真的是个警察，也有可能是个记者。
或者就是个平民，反正他调查探秘，它其实是个探秘，然后有一个秘，一个探秘就要做出自我牺牲。这种片子。
很多的啊行街探什么的。
呃，那个那个。
福尔摩斯。
如愿以偿，我们说一个愿望，一个咒语，一个教训。我们说沈腾那一类。
都属于这个类型的。
穿越类的也都是这个类型。
金凯丽也爱玩这个类型，如愿以偿来的。
然后麻烦家伙我们说星爷的。
青爷那一卦的都属于麻烦家伙，就一个家伙遇麻烦了，小人物出大事。
记录记住我说的口诀，他这个难记啊，记住我说的口诀，小人物出大事。
便签仪式。
这种呢就是很现实的一种题材。
就是一个常规的现实问题。
你用了一个过激的方式，一个不正确的方式。
去解决。
面对一个，比如说婚姻问题。
一个婚姻问题。
很常规的问题。
但是你选择了。
逃避。
走了，李亚初走了。
就是边疆仪式。
错误的处理方式，最后回归回来。
嗯。
上节课举例子了。
那叫什么？
呃，录取通知书。
触不可及对吧？可触不可及，可以去看一下啊，挺好看的。
而后娱热成功。
一个愚者面对一个伟业。
最后。
呃。
伪装的变化。
光说这个也挺拗口。
阿甘正传律正俏家人。
怎么去理解这种片子呢？就是。
一个小人物。
进到一个。
很高大上的环境。
这么说吧。
对吧。
他也有点像小人物遇大事，但是小人物出的这个大事儿是负面的。
这里呢他遇到的这个是个尾业，是个好事儿。
拔苗助长，你知道吗？是个好事儿，是摊上好事儿了。
是这么说的。
然后如愿以偿嘞。
跟这个的区别是，他上他让这个事儿看似是好事儿，但最后证明是个教训。
对吧我给你很多多少亿。
让你多少天内花完，看似是个好事儿，实际是个教训，我让你当一天上帝，你看似你牛逼，很厉害，其实是个教训，明白这个意思吗？这这这是微小的区别。最后这个被制度化。
着重讲的是个人跟群体之间的抗争和选择。
就是有一个群体。
也说不上对错，但是人家呢都一直在做自己的事儿。
就你较劲。
就你觉得我可不可以？
有另外一种方式和方法。
对吧飞跃风人怨也好。
还是教父也好。
这个群体没有所谓对错，它就是一种现象。你可以说他错了。
你可以说你错了。
反正是一种个人跟群体之间的抗争和选择。
这5个很明确。
这5个有一点。
有一点难理解。
讲的我都有点头晕了，更别说你们了。
是吧信息量确实大。
然后呢，这么讲也很枯燥，他们每个人有自己的定义，每个人有自己的元素。
我也有点缺氧，我试着给你们捋一捋，好不好？
我们用例子来捋吧。
我们不要去举别人的案例了，说什么人家大白鲨是这种片子，人家铁达尼是那种片子。
看怎么捋啊？
来。
我们说金羊毛类的片子，我们一个一个捋好吧，我们再拿出一节课时间来，再拿出。
一堂课的时间再来捋一下这10个故事类型，这10个故事类型你如果真的理解透了。
你能够把你的故事合进去。
找到。
一个。
一个位置，一个坑安进去之后，然后你再对照。
这个这个老师的要求，斯耐德的要求。
你能够迅速的把你的片子扶正。
至少不会出大事。
就像我说的，你不至于瘸一条腿，瘸两条腿，那就完了那就完了。
你可以知道你的你的这种类型的片子的7寸在哪里。
要劲儿的地方在哪？就像我说爱情片，你这个沟你不深，你就别扯了。你如果没有一个好勾，你就别拍爱情片了，是这个意思，明白吗？就那个七寸哪。
得很寸。
这拿的很准。
所以说咱再花一节课，我再给大家举一遍。
咱们自己的例子吧。
好不好？
琢磨琢磨啊。
找个简单故事往里套啊。
我们说金羊毛类的片子。
我之前讲八要素的时候啊，我给大家说过。
小蝌蚪找妈妈。
这个故事是个好故事啊。
就这个故事他一目了然。
开宗明义主角是谁？小蝌蚪，他要干什么？他要找妈妈。
特别明确。
特别明确，而且那个小蝌蚪找妈妈那个故事。
它就是个金腰毛。
他就是个金羊毛。
太明确了，他寻宝啊，还找妈妈呀，他路径太明确了，对吧？路径太明确了，一路上找呀。
然后呢。
我们回想一下它的原文好不好？
小蝌蚪找妈妈，他的寓言故事是这样的，一群小蝌蚪在河里玩很开心。然后呢，河岸上呢有几只小鸡。
小鸡在玩，然后小蝌蚪就跟小鸡一块玩。
对吧虽然隔着水面儿。
但是呢一起玩很开心，然后玩了一会儿呢，天色不早了，老母鸡来了，老母鸡来了，小鸡就回家了。
然后小蝌蚪就说再玩一会儿啊，小鸡小鸡就说，那我妈喊我了，我要回家了。然后小蝌蚪就看看妈妈。
我们为什么没有妈妈呀？
是吧。
他他他他又不是有个团队嘛？一群小蝌蚪，然后呢，就七嘴八舌说，那我去找吧。
我们也要妈妈就找妈妈。
来跟小鸡玩，这个这这是个什么事儿？
这是个激励事件。
鸡嘛？那不是个鸡利事件吗？这给激着了呀，对吧？让鸡给急着了呀，哎呀就你有妈妈呀，我也去找。
然后呢，就就开始找。
一路上找一路上找。
呃，去找那个呃呃，好像反正是找了鳗鱼，找了什么王八，反正找各种。
找到，然后说妈妈妈妈，你是我妈妈妈人家说不是不是不是是吧？有的还很凶，要吃他们。
完了一路艰难险阻吧，最后。
找到了啊亲妈那个那个大青妈对吧？
这是一个典型的。
金羊毛类型的故事。
我们说我们把小蝌蚪找妈妈这个故事。
他现在是个预言。
这个小童话，他构不成电影的。
他构不成电影了，它只是一个金羊毛类型的故事。
我们说我们如果把它写成金羊毛类型的电影，他现在缺什么？
我们这么写啊。
小蝌蚪。
是主角没有问题。假设是金刚毛啊，小蝌蚪是主角是没有问题的。
小蝌蚪上路找妈妈的动机。
不够。
是不够的。就作为一个电影啊，小蝌蚪找找妈妈。
可以作为他的动作。
但是不会是他的终极目标。如果是我写小蝌蚪找妈妈这个命题作文要写成金羊猫类型。
我们可以把妈妈更概念化一点。
他不是找妈妈。
他是找自己的身世。
我们说假设是金羊毛类型啊。
小蝌蚪寻找自己的身世。
一只小蝌蚪就一只。
就一只。
一只小蝌蚪。
在池塘里游。
油。
然后呢。
还可以有小鸡儿在那吃米，河里呢有有有有有有什么呃虾虎鱼，有小龙虾，还有一只河蟹，对吧？反正大家都在那玩。
小蝌蚪跟这些人一块玩，然后。
这些人就问。
你是个什么东西？
你是个傻？
是吧你到底是个啥？
小蝌蚪不知道自己的身世。
而且其他的小鱼、小虾、小螃蟹都有自己的伙伴，都有自己的家庭。
然后这个小蝌蚪。
一个小点点，小豆点儿，它自己在这个池塘里。
他等于是。
没有绅士。
明白这个意思吧。
然后呢，他看到别人都有妈妈。
他不知道自己是个什么。
他想跟鱼一块玩，然后鱼跟他说。
你游的没有我们快，我们不跟你玩，对吧？然后他就去跟瞎一块玩。瞎说哦，你没有虚子，我们不跟你一块玩，然后他就跟我那个那个那个螃蟹一块玩，螃蟹说我有腿，你没有。
然后等于是把小蝌蚪的身世。
成为了他的第一个want最重要的want。
然后呢，他决定去找他妈妈。
你看你这个路径就对了，就是说他其实是想想要寻找自己的身世。
这个宝啊。
这个奖励实际上是他的生死。
是他的身死。然后呢。
他的。
他的动作是找妈妈。
他认为我只要找到我妈，我去问他一下，我到底是个啥。
我是个鱼，还是个虾，还是个蟹。
哪怕是个王八也行啊。
对吧。
他就要去找。
等于找妈妈是个动作，哎，这个这样写这个金羊毛类的电影就出来了。
小蝌蚪因为自己的身世之谜，可能受到了一些歧视、冷落，或者是孤独寂寞冷。
踏上了征程，然后给他搞一个团队，搞一个团队。那。
搞一个团队，那么我们说这个团队一般来说是需要是是。
是他。
是与它相反或者互补的类型吗？
对吧你看啊。
小蝌蚪是一个缺少家庭的。
对不对？
那他的伙伴他现在要离开这个池塘，顺流而上。
到处去找妈妈，等于他要踏上冒险的征途嘛。那他的伙伴应该是一个。
家庭圆满。
父母慈爱，但是呢这小子叛逆呀，他觉得我妈什么事都管我，我要自由。
就是惯的，你知道吗？这个小子得是个惯的，也就是说他拥有小蝌蚪梦寐以求呃的的的东西，但是不知道珍惜。就是他的团队，你可以搞一个这样的配角。
搞一个王宝强。
你懂我意思吧？
就是。
小蝌蚪缺缺什么，他有什么嘛？小蝌蚪缺家庭，他就有家庭。
等于是一个被溺溺爱的惯坏了的一只。
王八。
对吧可以是只王八嘛。
就是小蝌蚪。
和一只王八。
他俩作为一个团队，结伴上路，寻找他是小蝌蚪的身世，动作是找妈妈。
那么他们一路上肯定是经历的艰难险阻。
遇到了一些有人想吃他们，遇到有人想骗他们，对吧？还遇到了发洪水。
还遇到了这一段路很难走，要穿过一段高速公路啊，河断了呀，要穿过一段高速。我为什么给他把大量选的王八没选没选一个呃那个那个虾虎鱼或者是小鲤鱼什么的，就是他要解决陆地那一段啊，我这这都是有设计的，你懂我意思吧？
公路片你得是有设计的，他俩为啥互补啊？经历一段没有水的时候，那王八要驮着它呀。
对吧王往要驮着他的呀。
所以说你看蝌蚪跟王八这一对儿呃，这个这个好兄弟。
踏上了寻找蝌蚪绅士的这个道路。
这种片子的路径一般是什么个路径呢？就是。
你肯定最后找到的不是你你要的东西。
明白这个意思吗？他一路上寻找他妈。
寻找他妈是动作，他的欲望是知道自己的身世。
我说最后要绕过动作实现欲望，就他根本没有找到他妈。
但是他长途跋涉，天天的找，天天的打听。
等到有一天，突然一照镜子。
发现自己长出了绿色的花纹。
尾巴也越来越小。
长出了后腿，长出了4条腿。
哦。
原来我是个青蛙呀。
明白这个意思吗？
他对自己的身世也不再有怀疑了，而且他对自己的身世的怀疑是有层次的。
他不是简单想知道自己的身世，是因为他在那个池塘的时候，那些人都不跟他玩，认为他没有价值，明白这个意思吗？最后一定要升高到价值这个层面。
小蝌蚪在一个池塘里面受尽冷落跟歧视，人家不跟他玩。
因为不知道你是个什么东西，也不知道你会干什么。他最后发现了自己一路上。
他发现了自己。
可以除害虫。
对吧？
可以帮助人。
可以这这个游泳，可以在陆地上走，开始是王八驮着他呀。后来我跟你讲，必然有一场戏王八翻盖了。
王八都不行了，就这段路太干旱了，你知道吗？这段路太长一段时间干涸没有水，王八都干的不行了。然后王八开始拖着他驮着他呀。王八王八相当于那个权力的游戏里面那个hold那个那个名字叫什么？反正驮着那个公子的那个。
他天天驮着他呀，说这段地方没有水，你坚持住，我驮着你，最后王八自己渴渴死渴的晕过去在那个。
干巴巴的河床里。
那这时候小蝌蚪。
突然意识到。
我天哪，我出来四条很嫩的。
小手小腿。
对吧虽然他很奇怪，我这我到底是个什么东西，越来越更怀疑自己的身世了。但是这时候自己有手有脚。
他反过来驮着王八。
对吧拽着他驮着他鼓励他或者去他驮不动，他可以到别的地方去找水灌一口水，回来给王妈喝，灌一口水回回来给王妈喝。因为他现在。
有手有脚了，虽然全部磨出血，很嫩。
但是他成长了。
明白这个意思吧？我有什么用？
我这个小蝌蚪我有什么用，我给你们看看我有什么用。
我是谁已经不重要了，他上路的时候是想知道我是谁，我是个什么东西，我到底有什么用？
但是最后他可以没有找到他妈妈。
当然你可以全部经历完这一切以后，突然发现远处一个绿色的池塘，有一群蛙叫。
他可以找到自己的团队，但我说过，结果不重要。
结果赠送就可以了。
但是更重要的是，他在这段路程中。
小蝌蚪意识到。
我是个蝌蚪也好，我是个鱼也好，是个虾也好，是个王八也好，都不重要。我就是我。
对吧。
我就是我。
我可以帮助别人，我可以帮助自己。
我不需要别人来定义我的身世，明白这个意思吗？我甚至不需要我妈来定义我。
所以他跟王八的这段旅程。
他的成长就是。
我他妈就是我。
我的奖励就是我知道我是谁了。
我门轻，我现在O我OK的，我可以做，我可以没问题。然后王八呢，王八也要成长呀。
王八要意识到。
家庭的温暖。
因为他是背叛家庭出来的。
他要意识到。
他断几个哥哥。
就先出壳的那几个哥哥肯定得到的宠爱。
多嘛，他会意识到那。
哥哥就是哥哥，父母就是父母，亲情愿打不断。
可以在某一场戏的时候。
他们他们俩走投无路的时候，对吧？蝌蚪跟小王八走走投无路的时候，回头一看，我操，远处有五六个盖儿，五六个圆黑色的圆饼都往这边捅是是王八他哥哥王八的几个哥哥天天欺负他的那几个哥哥和他爸爸妈妈赶过来了。
对吧来来救他们一把。
所以说你看如果是一个金羊毛类型的小蝌蚪找妈妈，那就是一个不知道自己的身世的池塘里面的野蝌蚪。
别人都叫他点点，对吧？因为你不知道你是个什么玩意儿。
开始还以为你是个养屎呢，后来发现会动。
然后觉得自己受尽屈辱又黑，对吧？人家借他黑袋。
觉得自己受尽屈辱。
然后想要寻找自己的绅世，然后寻找绅士的动作就是我要找到我的妈妈。
然后呢，大伙的就是王八就是一个被呃呃那个离家出走的王八。
然后一路上。
最后找到找到了自我，虽然没有找到妈妈，但是找到了自我。
明白了吧？激亚毛类型的片子。
小蝌蚪找妈妈。
我们说爱情片我们也来捋一个。
我们也来写一个好不好？